welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the slowest man
alive and this episode were breaking
down the final two parts of crisis on
Infinite Earths crisis hit the ground
running in December with three episodes
that tied together major parts of the DC
Universe and told a compelling story
about the destruction of the multiverse
after a month-long hiatus the series is
back with its final two parts and
throughout this video we'll be breaking
down everything you need to know about
the finale and its ending there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to check out the two
episodes yet and don't want to know what
happens then I highly suggest that you
turn off now without the way I just want
to give a huge thank you for clicking
this video now let's get into our
breakdown of crisis on Infinite Earths
okay so just a quick recap of crisis so
far the anti-monitor has been slowly
destroying Earth's across the multiverse
one by one in order to stop this the
monitor brought together Paragons but it
wasn't enough Oliver Queen sacrificed
himself the heroes visited many worlds
and slowly they formed a resistance the
anti-monitor ravaged the group but they
managed to make it to the vanishing
point a place outside of the multiverse
at the anti-monitor could not reach that
should have you all caught up and we
rejoined our heroes and last night's
episode of arrow since his death the
arrow has become something else
something more The Spectre he becomes a
key player in the events of the episode
with the character pretty much acting as
a guide to the Paragons in order to put
them on the path to destiny with the
anti-monitor arrow opens with a
flashback to Malthus 10,000 years ago in
this we see how Nauvoo create the
anti-monitor by journeying to the dawn
of time and this sort of kick starts the
two-hour journey with the main theme of
the double-bill that is memory and
connection Oliver utters the words there
are few things more powerful in the
universe than memory and connection and
this aesthetic is repeated several times
throughout early on this motif is
cemented here with Nobu and his wife
being showcased on screen is having a
deep and meaningful connection in their
relationship
so a sound of a certain a bit like a
Hallmark card there anyway they dis the
costume which ya I'm kind of glad they
brought attention to because because
this guy looks like he cause playing for
dead space but without the cool helmet
the memories of his past life is what's
driven the monitor to save the
multiverse as he knows that all life is
precious and this motif is echoed
throughout the entire run from here
Oliver journeys to the vanishing point
to reunite with the Paragons after
spending months there they're in
complete disarray and able to truly
fathom what has happened it's kind of
like just a season of Big Brother where
they never evict anyone and make them
spend two years there they mostly keep
themselves to themselves and since the
flash disappeared they've lived a very
bleak existence it turns out that the
flash run into the Speed Force to try
and free everyone from the vanishing
point but this has failed as time is
relative in the Speed Force in Barry's
mind he's only been gone a couple of
seconds but to the other Paragons this
has been a more agonizing wait and
putting the first three episodes in
December and the final two in January
what the hell were you thinking CW
anyway there's no way out of the place
at least that's what they think
with his new abilities Oliver rallies
the group together and gives Barry a
signal boost arrow has always been a
lone wolf a character that prefers to do
things on its own however here he
realizes that this task requires a team
a bond that will unite the group to save
the multiverse once more this ties into
the connection that all he speaks about
and he has finally realized that in
order to defeat the anti-monitor they
need to unite together Oliver has a plan
an epic way to deal with the problem
sort of sort of a bit like Skynet in the
Terminator basically but yeah basically
he wants to travel back to the dawn of
time with some Paragons in order to stop
Nauru from creating the anti-monitor as
with most time-travel stories this
doesn't work because in order for them
to need to go back to the dawn of time
then the anti-monitor has to exist and
so on and so forth and yeah it's a lot
of time uy me wibbly-wobbly stuff we do
learn however that Lex gave himself an
upgrade and this kind of plays into the
ending of the episode Nauvoo is always
going to create the anti
no matter what because of his ambition
and whether they stopped him 10,000
years ago or just before brexit his
existence is inevitable the attack on
the whole is a big failure with the
anti-monitor himself showing up during
the mission he knocks some of the heroes
into the speedforce
and left with little options Holly tells
Barry that he must go through his
memories and find the times that he
formed strong bonds and connections I
kind of felt that this was a bit poorly
handled and it just comes out of the
blue without any real setup like it told
us this throughout respectively and it
was a bit jarring when it was just
dropped on Barry however this is about
the memories connections and greatest
victories that Oliver made again this
ties back to the line that there are a
few things as powerful as memories and
connections and it's nice that they kind
of set up the overall arc to this
episode that ties in with the theme it's
a real walk or rather run down memory
lane with the flash visiting some major
moments in the CW vers history Barry
travels back to arrow season 3 episode
17 the Elseworlds finale and season 3
episode 8 everyone talk talk talks like
like like this this this now during the
run he comes across as Ramona's version
of the flash from the DC EU and it's an
awesome cameo that completely blew my
mind
I never thought crisis would tie
directly in with the movie universe or
even get a cameo this big but it was
awesome seeing him especially in the
wake of the news last week that the
flash movie would be a flashpoint event
when Ezra was cast as the flash a lot of
people cried out that Grant Gustin
wouldn't be the big screen version of
Hiro so it's nice to see the two kind of
acknowledging one another in what is the
best cameo in all of the Erebus in my
opinion anyway that that's completely up
to you whether you disagree or not he
mentions victor who is of course cyborg
in the DC EU and it's nice to know that
the characters live on even if their
movies are at a bit of a stalemate this
journey is a big travel back in time
that allows us to reminisce over some of
the big moments in aro history this is
going to be all of his final season and
episode and though the character could
return we did need a sort of trip
through the past
I love how great this show has been it's
a really bittersweet moment and it also
highlights how arrow has pretty much
been a linchpin of the TV DC universe I
mean it is called the arrow bus for a
reason and it's great seeing what pulled
everything together and this tribute
really sets up the final battle this is
an awesome fight here at the dawn of
time that really puts all of the budget
on the table
it's a massive special-effects Laden
battle that feels like the biggest and
most ambitious action scene that's ever
appeared in the arrowverse the Paragons
face-off against the shadow army and
Spectre goes head-to-head with the
anti-monitor also shoutout selects for
shooting stuff out with sound as well I
like that anyway everything at this
point sort becomes a bit meta physical
and metaphorical and met human
Metamorpho God with Olli becoming the
spark that relights the flame to start
up the universe
Lex helps them realize that they've been
put in place to find the flame and
together they all unite with Oliver to
strengthen him they managed to defeat
the anti-monitor but it's at the expense
of all of us life who dies as the
singularity forms and creates a
multiverse once more Sara and Barry
unite on the mountain and we watch the
character as he slowly passes away now
if you saw my Crysis episode one
breakdown then you'll know I felt like
all of his death felt a bit flat and
didn't really have room to breathe and
because of this it just felt like lustre
here it's completely different and the
character's death really has an
emotional gut punch to it we did know
that all he would die in crisis ahead of
time but it really hits home here I'm
not crying you're crying
anyway the universe grows and we then
jump to the second episode that
completely concludes everything before
we get into the second episode though I
just want to let you know we're giving
away a free copy of dr. sleep to one
random subscriber all you have to do to
be in with the chance of winning is like
the video subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on crisis in the
comments section below the winners gonna
be chosen at random on the 15th of
February in the cell be shipped out from
the enter forgets the price it's the
best of luck to everyone who takes part
so similar to the crisis on Infinite
Earths graphic novel the Reformation of
the multiverse has streamlined
everything together sort of shifting
things pretty much unto one earth Cora
Barry and
all realize that they now live together
on the same earth with Prime there's a
couple of hilarious moments such as Lex
getting a Nobel Peace Prize Marv Wolfman
who created crisis making a big big
cameo Bebo wrecking havoc in the street
and Black Lightning also asks how many
time the world almost comes to an end
and so on but yeah ultimately everything
is tied together now normally the
finales of mega events sort of wind
everything down but they actually use
the episode to cement the sacrifice that
Oliver made there's some major moments
and Sarah provides the episode with some
real heart with her clearly being torn
apart by the death of the character
everyone is in mourning and there's no
time to grieve and the shadow demons
return which cements that the
anti-monitor is still alive the arrow
bursts heroes all come together on that
collective earth to face down against
the big bad of the special but Oliver
they make one final stand it's another
big fight scene that sees the heroes
surrounding the anti-monitor and
attacking him from all angles as he
grows in size they manage to defeat the
anti-monitor with a sphere that'll
shrink for eternity and trap him in the
Microverse this is concocted by Ray
Palmer and Ryan Chau and for those who
don't know Chau is a version of the atom
in the DC Comics universe and it looks
like they are setting this up here the
episode ends with the president giving a
speech to the nation about all of his
sacrifice and we then see a reborn
multiverse with the families built
together through their memories and
connections do you say well I did there
a plaid in that hour was I brought it
all together in the end like a DC
special I did it the show ends with us
remembering the great hero but it also
sets at what is coming down the line
this Titans a green lanten verse
swampthing Doom Patrol and many many
more that really hit home just how
successful this universe is now I love
the Superman Returns moment and this is
an awesome call back to the Christopher
Reeves bit that is just one of my
favorite Easter eggs in the entire run
Clark and Lois talk about their sons
which sets up their upcoming show with
one another and the heroes spark of the
flame in all of his memory and old STAR
Labs facility and we see that they've
set up a Justice League table that has
all of the
emblazoned on the chairs surrounding it
there's also one with a green arrow
symbol on it that shows there will
always be a place for a green arrow at
the table and this could be hinting that
his daughter will be taking up the
mantle we get a nod to Glee ku if you
don't know is basically from the
animated series Super Friends and he's a
little tiny ape thing that he's gonna
cause some mischief if you don't like
pipo or he walks or pork sensory but
yeah this is kind of gonna be the
direction that they're going in anyway
we also see the Hall of Justice from
outside and with all of the characters
now on the same earth they can now truly
format JLA that connects the heroes with
one another so yeah it's a great ending
and after a couple of issues with the
opening episodes of crisis I have to say
these two final episodes were incredible
they ticked all of the boxes set up a
lot of things going forward and I can't
wait to see what happens in the
newly-formed arrowverse this was a
brilliant finale and yeah I'm very
excited for what's in store down the
line now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the finale of crisis and
what you want to see in the future
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please give it a
thumbs up make sure you check out our
video from yesterday in which you would
go over all of the theories for who the
boots in the mandalorian belong to you
you can also support the show by
subscribing to us on patreon and if you
want to come chat to us after the video
you can join our discord server in the
description below or follow us on
twitter at definition whitey that's the
best way to keep up to date with
everything we do at heavy spoilers and
hopefully we see over there very very
soon this is a channel for people who
are super into superheroes so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]